[Musique]
au moment où Montréal bah au rythme des
Francofolies et du Grand Prix en ce
début de saison estivale le chef du SPVM
fait did Daguerre adopte un ton
rassurant honnêtement je dirais aux
citoyens aux citoyens et il est très
sécurité à la ville chiffres à l'appui
pour les 5 premiers mois de l'année
comparativement aux quatre premiers mois
de 2022 le SPVM constate une baisse de
30% des crimes avec armes à feu non
seulement il y a eu moins de feu tiré à
Montréal mais on note également des
diminutions de tentatives de meurtre et
de meurtre par balle il s'agit pour nous
de résultats vraiment positif mais
je vous dirai passons les quatre
prochains mois puis on pourra se
reparler à l'automne le SPVM affirme
connaître les principaux acteurs du
crime organisé qui alimente le marché
des armes à feu les arrestations ciblées
auraient d'ailleurs permis d'établir
cette accalmie printanière les policiers
affirment avoir saisi plus de 367 armes
à feu donc 367 armatus sais parce que
j'aimerais savoir c'est qu'on décortique
combien ces saisons étaient effectués
par des patrouilleurs dans le cadre de
leur travail normal j'en ai postes de
quartier c'est que les patrouilleurs
nous disent écoutez pendant qu'on se
pavane à dire qu'on crée des espoirs ben
nous on est ce que j'ai l'expression les
sulfeurs on est au minimum on est au
minimum là alors c'est en terme
d'effectif mais il y aurait des nuances
dans l'annonce du jour du SPVM exercice
là j'ai tout relation publique assez
long terme on prend un bloc de 5 mois et
celui-là il fait notre affaire parfait
on note quoi qui peut contrebalancer ce
qu'il y a ce qui va être intéressant à
voir c'est la tendance à long terme
c'est ça c'est pour cela long terme je
vais être le premier à me réjouir ce
bilan en matière de violence armée n'est
que le portrait du début de l'année le
SPVM l'a voulu lui-même son
renseignement criminel lui indique que
le milieu criminel est en pleine
ébullition et que la saison estivale
pourrait être le portrait de réglement
de compte armée ici parce que Robida
Radio-Canada Montréal